economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando de
colombia y esa polémica que hay por el
millonario préstamo que le dio el
gobierno de ese país a la aerolínea
nacional
avianca santiago muy buenas noches mire
todo comenzó el sábado cuando el
ministerio de hacienda anunció un
préstamo de 370 millones de dólares a la
aerolínea que como sabemos atraviesa por
una compleja reorganización empresarial
el solo anuncio disparó hoy en más del
20 por ciento en las acciones de avianca
holdings cuyo socio germán efromovich
fue arrestado hace unos días en brasil
como parte de la operación de corrupción
conocida como la valla pto pero hay
quienes no estuvieron tan contentos como
los inversionistas en la bolsa a
santiago la opinión pública cuestiona el
hecho de que la hermana del presidente
del país iván duque sea una alta
ejecutiva de la empresa
la procuraduría pidió también
explicaciones al mandatario y de paso le
recuerdo que esa firma ya no es
colombiana sino panameña el congreso de
la república de hizo lo propio con el
ministro de hacienda la alcaldesa de la
capital
bogotá claudia lópez se sumó a las
críticas y dijo que los pequeños
empresarios llevan meses esperando
propuestas de préstamos para sobrevivir
pero no han recibido respuesta alguna la
defensa del gobierno es que lo que busca
es preservar el servicio a nivel
nacional que justamente se retoma este
martes
daniela cómo es eso que la organización
mundial del comercio se quedó sin un
director ni el brasileño roberto acevedo
salió un año antes de culminar su
mandato para unirse desde mañana mismo a
la multinacional pepsico como
vicepresidente ejecutivo
acevedo deja la entidad en uno de sus
peores momentos santiago usted debe
estar de acuerdo con esto miré a finales
de 2019 estuvo al borde de un cierre
administrativo por la reticencia de eeuu
de aprobar su presupuesto su sucesor
tiene la difícil tarea de concluir
acuerdos que favorezcan el comercio
global y dirimir largos conflictos
comerciales entre los diferentes países
el funcionario dijo en un comunicado que
el proceso de reforma de la omct debe
continuar para que siga el sistema
respondiendo a las necesidades de él
comunidad mundial y agregó que 5
operación todos los países estarán en
una peor situación
daniela hablemos ahora de argentina que
dio por concluida oficialmente la
reestructuración de su deuda y le puso
fin a varios meses de incertidumbre de
esta manera al lograr que la gran
mayoría de sus acreedores finalmente se
adhieran a su propuesta de canje de
bonos emitidos en dólares en plata
blanca esto quiere decir que 66 mil
millones de dólares que hacen parte de
su deuda externa ahora tienen nuevos
plazos de esta manera se van a ahorrar
casi 38 mil millones de dólares en una
década y va a bajar su tasa de interés
en alrededor de 4 puntos porcentuales
escuchemos lo que dice el presidente le
dije nosotros vamos a cumplir con
ustedes
pero déjeme recordarle lo mismo que le
dije el primer día que hablé con usted
deje que lo hagamos a nuestro modo
porque lo que nosotros no vamos a hacer
es pedirle a nuestra gente más
sacrificio en breve espero que
despejemos el obstáculo que es la deuda
con el fondo monetario internacional-
dejamos a argentina pasamos ahora hablar
de eeuu que anunció nuevas restricciones
a la importación de acero procedente de
méxico y de brasil así de santiago la
administración de donald trump dice que
los fabricantes de acero en especial en
los estados de pensilvania ohio y
michigan se han visto bastante afectados
por la pandemia por eso es necesario
frenar los envíos que les hacen desde
méjico y desde brasil en brasil se va a
reducir la cuota de importación sin
aranceles decir que en lo que resta del
año ya no pueden llegar a 300 mil
toneladas métricas sino a 60.000 y en
diciembre deciden que van a hacer en
2021 y en mexico va a haber una estricta
vigilancia hasta junio de 2021 de las
exportaciones de este material de
hablemos ahora de los indicadores bueno
wall street hay aunque dos de sus
principales índices cerraron en rojo
pues esta bolsa selló su mejor mes de
agosto desde 1984 y el nasdaq rompió un
nuevo récord
las bolsas europeas bajaron en medio de
las tensiones entre estados unidos y
china por la posible venta de 'tik tok'
y en américa latina un lunes muy oscuro
para las bolsas de sao paulo y méxico
impactadas por malos datos sobre la
situación fiscal de estos países y para
el día para el cierre los 6 mil millones
de dólares que invirtió warren buffett
uno de los más ricos de eeuu en acciones
de las cinco empresas japonesas más
valiosas en bolsa
el veterano que acaba de cumplir 90 años
dice que hacer mercado es el futuro
santiago
muchas gracias daniela por esta
información es todo en economía aquí en
france 24 feliz noche
[Música]